ross what are the differences between
being the head writer for television
show versus being one of the staff
writers
yeah um there's a huge difference even
when you're the number two person uh or
persons
on a writing staff it's not the same as
being
the head writer when you're the head
writer on the show
you've you're the decision maker and you
have to say
yes we're gonna that's the story we're
gonna develop or
i don't think that's quite right or all
those decisions you make
5 000 decisions a day whether it's about
a line or a joke or the word that to use
in the
description or a whole series arc for
for the
season you have to make tons and tons of
decisions and
there's a lot of pressure to that and
you know i tend to be
i always want to do my absolute best
work but i remember coming home one
night
and saying to my wife you know i had an
epiphany today
that it's not always about what's the
best possible story for the show for the
show
sometimes it's just what's the best
story i can come up with on a monday
and or that we can come up with that the
staff can come up with
um i think also when you're a staff
writer rather than
the show runner it can be frustrating
sometimes you have different ideas from
from the showrunner and you really
really know in your heart you're right
but you don't get to do it and so you
have to find a way to make peace with
that
on the other hand i found that when
especially my earliest jobs
cosby was my first staff job i learned
so much from the
experienced writers on the show i mean i
i was good enough to be allowed in the
writing room
but they had so much more experience and
had written so many more shows
and were so much more facile at
the work that needed to be done and had
just a
it's almost like i had the uh the play
school toolbox for how to write and they
have the real professional
three level toolbox of how to do it um
so i think that's actually one of the
joys of being a staff writer is
even though you may be frustrated
they're not doing it your way
i think you should say this is the
harvard graduate school of comedy
writing or drama writing if you're on a
drama
and i'm in a room with real seasoned
professionals and this is
a learning opportunity but it sounds
like also too being the head writer is
not always
what it's cracked up to be because then
you have the ones underneath
meta you know metaphorically that there
might be
you know tugging at what you want versus
what are some of these there is you know
there
look there's there's a room full of
people they're they're talented they
also all have
human foibles and egos and whatever else
uh
one of the rules i tried to set up in my
writing
room with the writers is i not only
think it's okay for you to disagree with
me i you know i
certainly hope you disagree with me
right up until the point where i say
okay i've made a decision and this is
what we're doing uh because at that
point i'm driving the bus and i've gotta
i've got to do that and by the way i'll
be wrongs a lot of the time
that's just the way it is but we can't
uh
just keep arguing in a circle over and
over again or we won't get our
our work done uh it's very demanding
that way
the other thing that's demanding about
being a head writer is that that's not
your only job you're also in charge of
the
budget of the show of looking at cuts of
this whole
machinery i think i once described the
job to someone as
it's as if you were at the plate in
baseball with the bat
but when the pitcher wound up he threw
nine balls at you and you had to pick
which one was the most important ball to
hit at that moment
and because you have to prioritize your
time everybody
needs something from you and so you've
got to learn how to juggle that
you've also got to learn how to trust
your staff then if you know
the room can't come to a grinding halt
the writing process
can't come to a grinding halt because i
have to be in editing for two hours
as part of my job you have to empower
the writers that are on your writing
staff
to feel comfortable moving forward and
not feel like
you're just going to shoot down
everything they they say and so
and of course you don't want to just say
yes just to make them feel good but
hopefully you've selected talented
writers and writer producers that can be
productive when you're not there
you